first let's start with how ABC news's
George Stephanopoulos and let's not
forget George Stephanopoulos worked in
the Bill Clinton White House so do you
think he has a political ideology here
he is reporting uh that there's a good
chance that the future president might
be a criminal or something like that I
guess he has plutonium and a DeLorean he
knows the future and we're gonna have to
impeach a sitting president blah blah
blah blah take a look
good morning and welcome to this week
one year from today there's a decent
chance that Donald Trump will be sitting
in a courtroom as a criminal defendant
there's a decent chance he'll be set to
accept the Republican nomination of
President of the United States
and there's a non-zero chance that he
could be both a criminal defendant and
the GOP nominee now none of this is
normal but that's the surreal world we
are living in today now that Trump is
the first former president to face
criminal charges from the federal
government his second criminal
indictment in the last three months
that's funny I do have to say that
nothing that George said there was a lie
all those things are possible it's
possible that a year from now uh Trump
will be in court it's possible that he
will be the nominee at this this point
you could Flash Forward two years from
now he could I suppose be like being
told he has to report to jail while also
being told that he's supposed to be
walking into the White House any of
these things are possible that doesn't
mean that any of them are legit that is
the issue so just to be clear let's get
you a little info on what's going on
from the daily wire related to Trump
former president Donald Trump said
Thursday evening that he has been
indicted in the federal criminal
investigation into his handling of
classified material the former president
added that he has been summoned to
appear at the federal courthouse in
Miami on Tuesday at 3 P.M okay so that
is later today now I want to be very
very very very very very very very very
very very clear about one thing here
their without question is selective
prosecution here if we are going to talk
about who screwed up with classified
documents then we got to look at Mike
Pence who has subsequently admitted it
as vice president and as vice president
you don't get to declassify documents
Joe Biden who did it as vice president
where you don't get to declassify
documents the president does Joe Biden
was the vice president at the time we
all know about the garage with the
Mustang and it was completely unsecured
and everything else so if you want to go
after Donald Trump who was president
doesn't mean he didn't make any mistakes
then you gotta have one set of rules for
everybody so I think the thing that most
people are outraged by right now is the
selective prosecution of Donald Trump
okay so that I want to be just very
clear about that put that in a box a
lock box and let's put that over here
all of that being said that does not
mean that Donald Trump did not do some
stupid and or illegal things I want to
read you one portion here from uh the
prosecution uh from the the affidavit uh
in August or September 2021 yeah at the
Bedminster Club Trump showed a
representative of his political action
committee his Pac who did not possess a
security clearance a classified map
related to a military operation and told
the representative that he should not be
showing it to the representative and
that the representative should not get
too close so that is the charge that is
one of the charges there's many many
charges if that's true like if you have
classified docs with maps of things that
people aren't supposed to see you can't
show them to people from your political
action committee you can't show them to
anyone who doesn't have that clearance
right so I think two things can be true
here this is an absolute farce and if
they want to go for Trump they got to go
for everybody but we know they're not
going to do that the Democrats control
the machine and they're trying to take
out Trump